today I'm making short rib ragout to
surprise my girlfriend it's her favorite
thing in the world I am CT and I can't
cook at all so my friends at tasty helps
me master this amazing short rib ragu
recipe and I know she's gonna love it
we're gonna start by seasoning the meat
in order to get a nice crust on the ribs
I patted down the meat with a paper
towel to take away any moisture as soon
as the meat hits the hot oil it will
immediately start to see her and create
a mired reaction which is exactly what
we're going for I tested this recipe a
few times to make sure it was gonna be
perfect for the video the first time I
cooked for Amber it was a complete
disaster and I am determined to redeem
myself no matter where we go out to
dinner if they're short of on the menu
Amber's gonna order it and I never get a
bite because every bite to her is
precious
I love taking amber out for dates and a
hopeless romantic we always have so much
fun when we go out together but I love
the idea of learning how to make her
favorite dish that I would take her out
to buy anyway so that we can spend more
time at home enjoying each other's
company when Amber cooks for me I can
hear her singing her heart out the
entire time from the other room she's
not only putting food on the table she's
putting her soul on the table
protip saute the vegetables and tomato
paste really well to deepen the flavor
and give it a beautiful color use a nice
red wine like a port to deglaze the pan
one of the ways to make it even more
tasty is to scrape all the bits off the
bottom of the pan with a spoon it's
actually called Fond and if you do I
think you'll be pretty fond of it this
tasty recipe might be the first time
that I'm cooking such an elevated dish
but I can already tell it's opening
doors of culinary creativity for me I'm
really excited to see where these
newfound skills take me before you know
it I'll be a dad with a grill searing
steaks stereotypes guys this dish tastes
rich the flavors are so deep that's all
due to getting a really good sear on
your meat browning your tomato paste and
then waiting until that meat falls right
off the bones this dish is so rich it
tastes like something you would have on
a really special occasion I have a
feeling Amber's gonna want me to make
this for every holiday from now on as a
queer kid growing up in a conservative
environment there were a lot of people
that told me I wouldn't have this happy
of a life and I wouldn't have a safe
home and I wouldn't be able to support
my partner the way that Amber and I do
and cooking this dish and putting it on
the table it smells like home in a way
that I'm just so proud of who I've
become
and how I'm able to contribute to my
happy and healthy relationship whoo I'm
all done now finally she's gonna be here
any minute I've got to go get dressed I
don't know how I'm gonna keep this
surprise I hope she likes it
[Music]
open your eyes I tricked you and I go to
myself thank you
oh I get what a surprise it's easy all
you get to do eat fries the fries oh
yeah oh oh yes